こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんアイスクリーム何好きですか？
世の中には色んなアイスクリームがあるんですけども
その頂点に君臨と言ったらもちろんこちら
皆好きだよね？
美味しさのレベルが違うんすよ
あぁめっちゃこぼしちゃった
ｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｯ　ﾓｯﾀｲﾅｲｯ!
今の一滴で勿体ないぐらい凄く高級なアイスクリームなんですよ
もう３００円ぐらいする
ｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｽﾞｯ　あぁ～旨い！
ホントうめぇわ！
ホントにもうハーゲンダッツのバニラっつったら
そこらへんのバニラのアイスクリームとは比べ物にならないくらい
美味しくなぁぁぁい！×２
一緒だよぉぉぉぉぉ
そこらへんのバニラ一緒だよぉぉぉぉ
一緒とは言わないんですけども、なんかこう…
値段とパッケージ、それでなんかこう…
補正がかかっちゃってんじゃねぇかなっていう説がありまして
ちょっとそれを今回検証してみようと思います
何気なくターゲットにえっとハーゲンダッツなんだけども
中身が普通のバニラアイスのやつを渡します
安い１２０円ぐらいのアイスをこうやってパクパクハーゲンダッツだと思って食ってたら
美味しい美味しい高級やぁとか言うと思うんで
その様を今回楽しもうと思います
多分バレないと思います
というわけで早速！
ハーゲンダッツの中身を変えていきましょうっ！
ﾊﾟｸｯ　ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ…　ｺﾞｸﾝ
まぁまぁかな…
MOWいただきます…
ﾊﾟｸｯ　うまっ！
同じくらいうまい！
ﾊﾟｸｯ　同じや！
完全に一緒ですわ　色だけじゃなくて
カメラマン）味も？　はじめ）味も完全に一緒ですわ
はじめ）ハーゲンダッツの方が美味しいと思ってるでしょ？
カメラマン）そらね、高いからね
スーパーカップが一番味が近かったので
今からハーゲンダッツのバニラを全部食って
空いたこのカップにスーパーカップのバニラを移して
一回冷凍して固めます
ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ…
やべ　しんど
はじめ）え、上手くない？　カメラマン）上手い！×４
はじめ）どう？×５　カメラマン）あ～ぽいぽいぽい！
はじめ）ぽいよね？ぽいよねっ？
比べてみますっ
やべーよコレ
はい、完成しましたっ！
はじめ）アイス食おうや×２
たくみ）アイス？
はじめ）だいちくん買って来てなかったっけ？
たくみ）あぁ　そう
だいち）あぁそうそう　買ってきたで俺
たなっち）そうアイス買ってきたのに　はじめ）また買ったの？
だいち）俺いつもアイスしか買ってない
たなっち）はい
たなっち）えっあっ　ホントに　ハイ
たくみ）ありがとうございます
たくみ）溶けてる
はじめ）食べよ×２
たくみ）食べようや
ﾊﾟｸｯ
はじめ）ちょっと溶かしてあんの？
はじめ）うめぇなぁ
たくみ）うん
はじめ）普通のバニラと比べては美味しいよね
だいち）確かに全然違う
はじめ）ミルキーってことだね　たくみ）うん
はじめ）強い？あのバニラ感は　スーパーカップより
（エンディング）
たくみ）まさか…
はじめ）中身は…
はじめ）スーパーカップでしたぁ！
たくみ）えぇ！？
たくみ）全然分かんなかったぁ　はじめ）えホントに分かんなかった？
たくみ）え！？
たくみ）こ…高級感あるなって…
ｗｗｗｗ